we know there's some sort of
game-changing twist this season we've
been told there's a game within a game
when you heard that the rules were
changing once
again what was your reaction my life
this season of all stars is going to be
a game within a game
i am guy kyle the girls are out for
blood
we've been saying that it's a gag within
the game not a game within the game it's
a gag
within the game in the game yeah i like
that
100 well it didn't gag me because i lost
that reflex
years ago
[Laughter]
you know it is it is a surprise though
it's like the hunger games meets
all stars
can my all-stars rise to the chalice
let's do this
whenever i found out what was even
happening [ __ ] i was gaggity goopy
swooped i was like
i didn't even know this was a thing and
apparently it was told to us on the
first day and we were all just like
okay yeah literally you were like
cool yeah it's all stars it's different
that just goes to show you how much of a
whirlwind and a
true race marathon this competition is
that they've announced a rule change and
it just kind of went over everybody's
head
we hear mama ru talking but it's kind of
like okay girl let's get
let's go like let's just get it going
our feet are hurting
i completely blacked all that out they
love to throw that little curve ball
so i went in just kind of no
expectations
open mind ready to take it as it came
and
i'm glad that i went in with that
mindset because i think let's be real
rupaul and
michelle and them love the movie show
girl where they just had those marbles
in their hands it was like
down the stairs you go and that that
understands we all went
who caused the most drama this season
rupaul caused the most drama she makes
us pixel lipsticks so
i mean boom there you have it all sizes
of game of friendships and strategy
you want to be here show it this is
redemption time
she starts the drama and she always
comes in the room and finishes the drama
too
i mean honestly that is the drama really
when you get to the nuts and bolts of it
all is like
us having to pick lipsticks is where the
drama comes from you know otherwise
there's really not like you know what i
mean
that's where it all starts because it's
like oh but you're gonna choose me
you're gonna choose heart like
people are like having to plead their
case it's just it's a really
an emotional experience like being the
judge is hard
i think the question of like the
integrity when it comes to the voting is
the thing that's the most
dramatic about the season like that's
the 14th queen of the season
if you had to describe your all-star six
experience in one
word what would your word be memorable
i'll say
iconic the glow up thickening
okay in my one word i would use
impactful
because this season i went in and i
didn't hold anything back why should i
you know
a million girls could have got an
opportunity to come back
but they called me and so i had to come
back and do my thing
and pandora how would you describe this
experience i don't know there's two
words like
surreal and intense
expensive i would say
triumphant you know win lose or draw i
feel like this is
my time to really like be me for the
first time
on drag race and so i feel very
triumphant about that
i love it triumphant inexpensive because
we know the girls spend a
cute coin to look like an all-star
ryan murphy paid for my all-stars
[Music]
package